you know I'm still tasered by that Fabby
uh that final game because essentially
nepo King literally went from G2 to B7
that was one Brave King and sabii had an
extra Pawn NEPA demonstrating the power
of Queen and Knight and we had a
fantastic end to that game let's take
let's take a look a little slow motion
it's and remember no time on the clock
that his King has just gone all the way
up the board and he's calculated already
a king and P calculated with seconds on
the clock to Precision that white just
grabs that final C5 pawn and black
doesn't have the moment to push the G
Pawn anymore has to waste the tempo
shouldering white King right there which
gives Yan the momentum to stop pushing
the D Tempo D4 if not for the move King
E5 there was the move King D4
Peter time yeah stop the je on very
impressive game by